au liban la contestation ne s'essoufle
pas elle prend même un nouveau tournant
après l'annoncé de la nouvelle équipe
gouvernementale ce mardi les
manifestations ont repris de plus belle
au fil des semaines la tension n'a cessé
de monter
comme le week-end dernier où plus de 500
personnes avaient été blessées lors
d'affrontements à beyrouth
c'est insoutenable ils sont en train
d'attaquer les gens les manifestants
d'une manière qui ne qui n'a rien à voir
avec les droits de l'homme il ya des
distances pour les balles en caoutchouc
qui sont de 35 mètres minimum ils sont
en train de tirer à trois mètres nous
avons plus de 500 blessés depuis le
week-end le peuple a faim le peuple n'a
pas les moyens de payer son loyer nous
voyons de plus en plus de familles
descendre habiter dans la rue ils
peuvent pas payer les écoles ce n'est
pas un gouvernement d'une seule
coalition qui va pouvoir régler cette
crise le pays qu'il y à peu faisait
encore figure d'exemple dans la région
pour le côté pacifique et festive de ces
manifestations est confronté à une
flambée des violences
vitrines de boutiques de luxe et de
restaurants brisé distributeurs
automatiques vandalisés ces actes
révolte une partie des libanais c'est
douloureux et décevant cette destruction
ne doit pas avoir lieu
la révolution a besoin d'être protégée
maintenant parce que nous ne pouvons pas
tout perdre à cause de quelques vandales
si la classe politique est accusé de
corruption au liban elle est aussi
malmenés à l'étranger comme lors du
dernier forum économique de davos où
l'ancien ministre gébrane bassil a dû
répondre sur son déplacement en suisse
comment êtes vous venu ici comment suis
venu ici
avez vous pris un avion privé je suis
simplement venu sur mes propres deniers
vos propres deniers les ministres ne
gagne et il peint environ 5000 $ par
mois comment avez-vous affrété un avion
avec 5000 $ par mois pas une livre
libanaise aux dépens du trésor public
libanais
c'était donc l'argent de la famille non
cela m'a été offert
j'aimerais avoir des amis comme ça cette
crise au liban et non seulement
politique mais aussi sociale et
économique
elle intervient sur fond de
licenciements de masse de restrictions
bancaires drastique et d'une chute de la
monnaie nationale le liban croule sous
une dette qui représente une fois et
demi son pib l'un des taux les plus
élevés au monde
[Musique]